hello and welcome to top use cases to
start your serverless journey
my name is rachel style product manager
for serverless at google cloud today i'm
joined by my colleague preston holmes
we'll cover the benefits and use cases
of using google cloud serverless compute
we'll start with why modernizing is
beneficial for everyone whether you're
an established enterprise or a fast
growing digital native
we'll cover why google cloud serverless
will dive into why serverless is a good
fit for pragmatic enterprises and then i
will hand it over to preston talk about
great workloads for your serverless
journey
let's start with why modernize
as we look towards the future there is a
growing need for companies to create
value through application design
companies are looking to delight
customers with responsiveness derive
value from data and be insights driven
respond faster to change quickly and be
secure and available in regions globally
they also want to be well run with
effective cost management while being
able to scale quickly to potentially
millions of users
these characteristics are no longer just
a choice but an expectation from
customers
but
companies face barriers internally these
include people and organizational
barriers like a lack of confidence and
new technology
a need for control a lack of native
skills
a lack of automation
it can also be resistance to change high
tech debt lack of innovation lack of
cost optimization and the need to comply
with security policies
overcoming these barriers with the cloud
native strategy is important as modern
applications are able to achieve
outstanding outcomes including being
dynamic scalable and intelligent
these characteristics are increasingly
important for them to meet fast changing
user needs
a cloud native strategy is possible
whether your company is migrating from
virtual machines or building new
applications cloud native
when a company is migrating from vms
they often face tight budgets security
concerns the need to maintain legacy
infrastructure and the need to migrate
and modernize their apis
modernizing to serverless can help meet
many of these demands in a way that is
developer friendly while considering
cost and time to market
similarly building new applications
require services to be built in a way
that reacts to market and customer
demands
for these new applications we developers
want to use the latest technology we
don't want to think about upgrades we
want to take advantage of the new
economics provided by the cloud
and we want architectural portability so
we are not locked in
no matter where you are starting
serverless is a great choice and meets
demand of modern applications
now
let's explore why google cloud
serverless
serverless is a set of characteristics
it simplifies the developer experience
by eliminating the need to manage
infrastructure it is scalable out of the
box whether you want to scale down to
zero with no traffic or up to millions
of users
it has a pay as you use model where you
pay for exactly what you use instead of
guessing a capacity up front if you
don't have any traffic you don't pay for
anything
serverless technology enables companies
to quickly build develop and deploy any
application in a fully automated
environment
it removes the operational burden of
infrastructure management with built-in
security operations and devops best
practices
as our customer needs have evolved we've
built our serverless compute portfolio
to enable them in their journeys
as many of you know app engine was one
of the first serverless solutions to
market in 2008 and early customers took
advantage of serverless and app engine
as they scaled their web applications
across millions of users on google's
infrastructure
we then added the ability to run
functions as a service to our serverless
portfolio in 2017.
with cloud functions we give customers a
simple developer experience with the
ability to rapidly write and run tiny
snippets of code
in parallel google also introduced
innovations to the container market with
kubernetes and we started to hear from
customers who wanted to know if we could
combine the two awesome serverless
attributes of auto scaling and developer
experience with the flexibility of
containers
in response we introduced cloudrun the
next generation of serverless serverless
is no longer about event driven
programming or microservices
it's also about running complex
workloads at scale while preserving a
delightful developer experience in fact
serverless of cloud run is about having
a true developer platform with the
flexibility to run any language any
library any binary
serverless offers the following benefits
the infrastructure is managed by google
meaning that you benefit from deploying
on the same infrastructure as google
engineers
your engineers do not need to think or
spend time worrying about scale
because you only pay for what when there
is traffic it often enables
great cost savings
and finally serverless is secure google
manages infrastructure level security
for you ensuring that you have the
latest patches you can choose
from a suite of google cloud security
features to meet your business needs
google cloud serverless is the pragmatic
choice for enterprises and it's not just
for lightweight applications like this
zippy golf cart you might imagine here
we're actually enabling all kinds of
heavy-duty workloads like this tractor
in fact this year we unlocked several
security features on cloud run making it
even more secure for enterprises with
binary authorization and managed secrets
you can ensure your application is safe
to run
with cloud armor support identity aware
proxy ingress settings and i am ingress
you can ensure the right folks have
access
and finally
you can understand what your application
can access with restricting
egress out of vpc intelligent security
recommendations and vpc sc network
egress settings
we've also unlocked new pricing options
on cloud run
out of the box you only pay for what you
use rounded to 100 milliseconds
and this year we introduced committed
use discounts meaning that if you commit
to one or three years
you can save up to 17 percent
and finally we also introduce cpu
allocation controls meaning that if you
have a workload that needs to run
continuously we do not charge for
service fees to start cloud run back up
every single time
in addition all our serverless products
offer built-in observability and
monitoring without setup for example
request and container logs are
automatically sent to cloud logging from
cloud run and error reporting is
automatically enabled for cloud run
no additional setup or configuration is
required you can simply view logs on the
cloud run page and also in the cloud
logging console
choosing how google cloud server lists
can help eliminate operational overhead
manage costs
on it all on an innovative building
model with easier scalability now i'll
hand it over to preston to see what
workloads are a great fit
thanks rachel
so let's talk about some of these
workloads
you'll note that in google cloud
platform we have a range of options to
run the compute portion of your
application code
and these can be broadly laid out on
spectrum between convenience and control
so we've got cloud functions for very
small lightweight snippets of code we've
got serverless containers with cloud run
we've got cluster-based infrastructure
and kubernetes and gke
and then for vms we've got google
compute engine
so many of these workloads are
potentially a better fit for one of
these than another but rather than
create a large decision tree we've
decided to pick out three workloads that
we think are particularly good fit for
serverless and cloudron
and those are web applications
data processing and apis now i'll
actually speak to a little bit of a
subflavor of each of these to give it a
bit more
context of where you can get started
and so for web applications i'm going to
talk about intranet web applications so
these are applications designed to be
accessed only by company employees
and what we want to do we want to bring
you a bit of how we get to interact with
our internal applications of google
which google has published some research
about we call beyondcorp and that is at
google we no longer use vpns to access
internal applications instead we use
very secure identity aware proxies that
can use context about an employee to
make sure they have access only to the
right internal applications
now we have externalized this in cloud
platform as the identity aware proxy and
we can put that in front of our
serverless cloud run applications
the idea of iap is that we only want
authorized and corporate employees to be
able to access those internal
applications and they should not be
accessible by the public but at the same
time we don't want to burden our
internal developers with having to
recreate and reproduce a secure posture
for each new intranet application
instead that should be globally handled
by a front-end system that will make
sure only our employees are accessing
these applications
now this is specifically delivered
through a composition and integration of
google cloud platform products it starts
with cloud identity which provides an
identity service so that we know who it
is that's logging into our web
applications
it can then be guarded with cloud armor
a web application for our firewall that
does things like rate limiting
protection of our applications or can
white list certain ip ranges
we then hit the identity aware proxy
this gives our users that user login
flow so it makes sure that every
access to the actual application has
been authorized and the only identified
users are logging in
and then finally the load balancer
distributes these requests to multiple
different intranet apps
so let's take a look at a demo of this
in practice and see what it can look
like
at your company
so here you can see the intranet project
i have set up with several example
applications already deployed i have an
intranet home app this acts as sort of
the home page for listing all of my
other applications and then a birthdays
application and a vacations application
you'll note that the ingress setting for
all of these is set to internal and load
balancing what that means is that these
are not reachable
as directly from the internet you can
see while this url is here it's grayed
out and is not directly accessible
this is actually enforced for any new
cloud run
application deployed through
organization policy so for the entire
project or maybe a folder of projects i
can set that the only allowed values for
this ingress setting is internal traffic
only or internal plus load balancing
so we are running these applications
behind the load balancer and we have two
back-end services set up the first is
really just used as our catch-all to
route to that intranet home page
the other is using a wild card pattern
in the
host rule
and what that wild card pattern does is
allow us to use a single
masked applications network endpoint
group this network endpoint group takes
advantage of a feature with its own url
mask there and this service placeholder
in the url mask means that for every new
intranet application i deploy that has a
service name
i automatically have the route set up to
reach that particular cloud run service
in the single load balancer without
needing to
manually create each additional
backend for each new internet
application
now the beyond core part of this is that
i run these behind the identity aware
proxy this will force the login flow to
reach these applications
i actually have this set up to use our
organization only as a source of
identity so this is limited just to our
organization
the last thing we'll do here is just
check on
public dns google to see that the domain
name i have set up with my load balancer
is resolving
and it does it resolves to this ip
address which is the same
as that setup in the load balancer here
so with that let's take a look at what
the login flow looks like again this
will be the first time login for user
and if i do that i'm given a standard
login dialog here this is using in this
case of my google account but we could
also use a corporate sso flow
for iap
and now i'm on the internet home page
now i'm seeing a couple other of the
applications i can get to so for example
i can schedule some time off
this will route me to the vacations
service that is got its own sort of
hostname path behind this load balancer
i could also go to the birthday service
and again this will route to that
individual cloud run service so each of
these can be independently managed and
deployed by different groups or teams or
authors
and in fact you see that iap will pass
through information about the logged in
user so applications can make use of a
already authenticated value for the
current user to do things like user
specific profiles or updates or further
rule-based authorization
now subsequent logins to this will not
require any particular auth flow and
except subject to sort of any timeouts
policy of my org is set up because this
is using cookies to remember this login
for some period of time
if i try to log in as a user from some
non-organization user account
you'll see that i don't even have the
option of logging in
because the entire
oauth application is limited to only
organization users so this will be
another
layer of defense that prevents anyone
from accidentally enabling specific
permission to a user that's an option on
iap that you can set up and either
allow that or not allow that so it's
you're not forced to do that but if you
do want to keep this as an organization
only internet setup you can do that
and so deploying a new intranet app is
pretty much just as easy as now
deploying another container-based cloud
run service
each of these scales down to zero makes
it very easy
great now that we've taken a look at
internet web applications look at let's
take a look at data processing now data
processing is really a catch-all or
umbrella term that might cover any
number of types of changes or mutations
you're going to make to the data you
have which include converting data
packaging data validating data so it
really covers a wide range of use cases
so let's take a look at something that's
a bit more specific which is performing
some lightweight data processing at the
time of ingest
now on cloud platform we have a product
called cloud pub sub which is really
great at delivering messages to many of
our backend data processing systems
and as an architectural component it's
often very useful to decouple the
producers of data from those systems
which will consume it but there are
times that you need to bring data into
your platform this might be video game
telemetry might be device data it might
be some sort of external log ingest
where what you want to do is not
completely decouple this at the point of
ingest so you might want to provide
custom authentication at the point of
ingest or you might want to validate the
contents of each message and make sure
that only good and verified data is
making it onto the pub sub topic
and so cloud run acts as a very nice
scalable point of ingest where you can
both receive the data into gcp as well
as perform some lightweight data
processing at that point of ingest
another one of the use cases we want to
talk today is about rest apis now rest
apis are not a brand new use case in
fact they've been around a while but
they still remain a real bread and
butter of many enterprise it projects
this is often where you have
multiple services in the back end
composed into a single api service where
each
back-end microservice might be only
contributing one element of an overall
api experience so in this case we have a
hypothetical weather service where you
might have alerts
forecasts locations each being fulfilled
by a separate backend and independently
deployed microservice now these are all
routed through some sort of api
management system often serving the need
of authentication or rate limiting or
quota management
and then these reach the end user
application and either a client or a
mobile web application
one of the customers using cloud run in
this case is ecobee
ecobee uses cloud run for api services
driving experiences and functionality in
their customer facing web and mobile
applications
this has allowed engineering teams to
ship new features to their customers
faster as new services can be turned up
in days and iteration is made faster by
using the same serverless technologies
to simplify qa environments streamlining
the path from code to production
by using fully managed databases
together with serverless compute
services scale smoothly and reliably as
a whole
these technologies have led to greater
operational efficiency removing many of
the incident pages which were due purely
to infrastructure issues instead of the
applications themselves
and with that i want to thank you on
behalf of rachel and myself for joining
us today